how do I shoot me oh that's whoa what
was that
oh god that's what I do
oh crap where's that made lose Arrested
Development watch it
oh she's posted thing an old lady find
it old lady do this enough
come here come here come here okay John
Doerr watch him punch them then oh I
don't know what you wanted for me they
were shooting me ooh
oh wait I have one all right don't tell
me what it does just give me the okay
left left
l1 right right r2 left
[Music]
you're welcome wait what
what's that gonna do for me I don't know
gonna go nuts no one on the back of the
taxi that's perfect let's watch Wade
attack say for ten minutes
moon gravity was enable that would have
been much fun what's the code from
gravity you don't do them
hey wait there's a river in there this
is your super specialty am i right right
right right I bet you could swim away
for you to swim Annette if you could
swim die jump and fall yeah Circle
Square and then circle and that she
didn't work at all no it's gotta go the
ocean eventually just run and tell you
[Laughter]
there's a faster you told me not to tell
you what it was for you give me
something interesting to tell you oh
yeah he did say that so give me
interesting code it's pretty internet
fast swim is not one you would imagine
exists because those make it interesting
for us I'm sure the viewers sorry looks
a lot how do I focus or something not
interesting but viewers like comment
subscribe if you think that the fast
swim sheet is really interesting and
waves just being a sourpuss well you
lost your stars Oh God that's not good
l1 l2 what is this for I want to know
you can't know it's not the deal no one
else this one is interesting okay
l1 l2 r1 r2 left right left right
l1 l2 r1 r2 left right left right
what does that do
[Music]
oh my god wow that looks bad
how do I get a parachute first no that's
not part of the deal how many are there
Oh more than that I've seen at least
three worth I know my hand that's good
ray thanks Luce you don't even know who
that is
I'm gonna make that references if I lose
there I'm gonna cut up your audio so
that it sounds like I hate whatever the
films arrested
nailed it exile be one words I didn't
need a fairy did you do oh well that's
what I wanted to do next I went oh don't
don't crash into my plane damn Hey
people suck to be honest would you
expect your plane to magically appear in
a well this might not be the best
takeoff that's ever taken place like all
they're just crowding in now like whoa
we just oh yeah he's turning oh yeah
yeah let me just do that backup reversed
in your plane give me
just get me some [ __ ] this is
exciting
I just get want wah-wah-wah guys like
waited to fight just anybody I couldn't
be able to take off just taking off my
propeller break off totally did now it's
just so weirdly shaped go oh god you're
never gonna be able to get out of there
okey-dokey Oh put my tommy gun away
well hot tub swam it's like Assassin's
Creed up in here yeah
Batman oh oh yeah that guy's not played
the replacement glass people in this
universe must be Supercenter oh oh oh
there's not laughing it way to say this
you were laughing you know slapping
because my hood Oh
it's my natural life everyone says if my
life is like weirdly contagious and it's
very totally fake close my lap I did a
scan three that was no I will replay a
back and forth combined into bobwhite
accurate to mine that I just did why
because it's funny to make fun of boy
[Laughter]
you also can't be false enough to a car
that you're ready trying my jacket all
right try like right right right
like right there why your [ __ ] plate
Xbox Nabu triangle right right left
right a circle
what's a swear no x2 circle alert
yeah X on the Xbox is square on the
PlayStation yeah that's right Oh see I'm
not bad wrong party well what I said - I
said are he did not say - he said you
said one okay all right why is
essentially why should I try
our 100 so slidy thanks yeah this kinda
slide oh god that's super useful get
some scars
alright opps I'll find someone oh that
means the cop cars are slow oh no I'm
going down here ok alright so long as
your hug yeah holy crap so suddenly
you're going hyper speed do it again
watch out for that car
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]